-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy-nominated comedian you know
from his work on "SNL,"
"30 Rock," and "The Last OG."
He stars in the new film
"Spirited," which is in theaters
November 11th and available
globally on Apple TV+
November 18th.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Tracy Morgan, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey.
-Yo, yo, that dude
is not from Germany.
-Benny Greb?
-No, he's from Canarsie.
-Oh, really?
He's not? He's from Brooklyn?
-Brooklyn.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-You recognized him?
-I went to high school with him.
[ Laughter ]
-So why do you think he's doing
this cover story?
-Yeah, I don't know
what he's doing.
He's running some type of scam,
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Insurance or something,
I don't know.
-It's so helpful when you're
here because I feel like you
have such a good eye
for scam artists.
-Yeah. I used to be one.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Now that I think of it, Benny --
-Everybody thinking
I was a comedian.
-Oh, really? So the --
[ Laughter ]
Very, very inter--
Now, Tracy,
I love to have you here
to get your bounce on the news.
We had midterms this week. I
know you're a bit of a politico.
-Yeah.
-Did you stay up late?
Did you follow it all?
-It was a race, I mean,
it happened and then, like,
you don't know. I won.
-Oh.
-I'm the king of New York.
-King? I didn't even realize.
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm ruling over everything.
I'm ruling over Brooklyn.
-Okay.
-Manhattan.
-Queens.
-Okay.
-And the Bronx.
Everything except
for Staten Island.
-Okay, gotcha.
-That's Wu-Tang's territory.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, okay.
So you're king of four
out of the five boroughs.
That's very exciting.
-Yes.
And one of my first rulings,
I'm going to be the head coach
of the Giants.
-Really?
The Giants are actually doing
pretty well this year.
-Yeah, I love them.
We're gladiators.
You know what John Lennon
called New York City?
-What did John Lennon --
-He called it Rome.
-Oh, wow.
-This is the center
of the universe.
-Gotcha.
-Mm-hmm.
-So this is exciting that you're
taking over --
You're the king of New York.
You're taking over the Giants.
Now, as a coach, what would be
the first rule
you would have as a coach
in the NFL?
-I would change the lunch.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody's eating
pork and beans and franks.
[ Laughter ]
Cowboy food.
-Yeah.
Oh, that's very exciting.
You feel like maybe things have
gotten a little too nutritious,
and you go back to the old ways.
-Absolutely.
Whatever happened to knishes?
[ Laughter ]
-That's true. You feel like --
-I love knishes.
-Uh-huh.
-I used to go to
Coney Island a lot.
-To go have a knish?
-To have a knish.
-There you go.
See, I find out new stuff
about you every time
you're here.
-You didn't know this about me?
-I didn't.
-All them years on
"Saturday Night Live,"
you didn't know I love knishes.
-You kept this knish secret,
yeah.
Hey, I heard you're very
excited, I mean, I think we all
are about the new Black Panther
movie, "Wakanda Forever."
-Yeah, I auditioned for it.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
-I auditioned for "Black Adam."
-Really?
-I'll audition for anything
with the word "black" in it.
[ Laughter ]
-Great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So what happened at the audition
for "Wakanda"?
-They didn't hire me.
-Okay.
-They said I looked like
Garfield with my tights on.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-They don't know what
they talking about.
-That would work agai--
Yeah, I would say that maybe,
but you'll still see it.
You're still excited to see it.
-How much you selling
that guitar for?
[ Laughter ]
-Will you please stop trying to
buy my instruments?
-I need to buy the guitar!
If she ever got on crack,
she would sell that for $20.
[ Laughter ]
-Oy, if there's ever a reason
not to be on crack,
I guess it's that.
-Let's not act
like crack don't exist.
[ Laughter ]
My aunt was on crack, man.
-Oh, well.
-She bought me a Gameboy
for Christmas one day
and then she stole it.
[ Laughter ]
And then she helped me
look for it.
[ Laughter ]
All crackheads do that.
-Well, that's
a lovely Christmas story.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, is it true, speaking of
Christmas, you know, I think
people might want to buy
some new sneakers maybe.
You have a new shoe line.
-Yeah, I got a new shoe,
a new brand called
Tray Back 3000s.
They look like flip-flops but
they built to take the elevator.
-Oh, wow.
-Because I got hit by a truck.
I'mma be taking no elevators.
[ Laughter ]
My sciatica be acting up.
I go to strip clubs and be
pushing women off my lap.
[ Laughter ]
You know I got sciatica!
-Wow.
Now, how would they know you
have sciatica?
-'Cause I tell them!
-Oh, well, there you go.
-Before I tip them, I tell them
I got sciatica.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Tracy, can we take
a quick commercial break
and then can I ask you
about your new movie?
-They going to give me
some money?
-I mean, we can work
something out.
-Go on and take it.
-You guys, we'll be right back
with more from Tracy Morgan.